Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
"Hâkim Bey,
ektiğiniz fidanın ilk meyvesini
siz de yemek istemez miydiniz?"
Bir diğeri:
"E köydeki herkesle birlikte olmuştu,
e ben babasıydım,
benimle olmayacak mıydı?
E zaten çok da düzgün bir kız
değildi benim kızım.”
Ötekisi:
“Güzel kızım, seni her gün
böyle sevmemi ister misin?”
Alt katımızda, yan dairemizde,
üst katımızda,
en yakın arkadaşımızın evinde,
şimdi şurada bir yerde
ışığı sönen dairenin içinde,
kimler neler yaşandığını bilebilir mi?
Hayır.
Onlar bilebiliyorlar mı?
Çünkü bunu yaşadıklarında,
istismara uğradıklarında
üç yaşında bir çocuktan bahsediyoruz.
Normalde zaten babaların öyle sevdiğini
zannederek büyüyor bu çocuklar.
Mesela ortaya çıkan bir vaka:
Çocuk sekiz dokuz yaşlarında,
ilkokula gidiyor.
Teneffüste arkadaşları ile konuşuyor.
“Babam beni böyle seviyor,
sizi de böyle seviyor mu babanız?”
“Siz yatarken ne giyiyorsunuz?”
Çocuklar diyor ki: “Gecelik.”
Kız diyor ki: “Ben de gecelik giyiyordum,
ama artık kot pantolon
giymeye karar verdim.
Çünkü babamın o kot pantolonu
çok daha zor açabileceğini düşünüyorum.”
Çünkü zaten çocuk normalde
babalar böyle sever diye büyümüş.
Neyse bu çocuklar akşam eve gidiyor,
annelerine anlatıyorlar,
o anneler ertesi gün okula geliyor,
öğretmenle konuşuyor;
çocuğun annesi çağrılıyor ve o çocuğun
istismara uğradığı ortaya çıkmış oluyor.
Çocuğun annesi parçaları birleştiriyor
ve ahlar vahlar içindeydi diyor olayın
avukatı; bana bunu anlatırken annesi için.
Ve bu çocuk dört yaşından beri
babasının açık açık istismarına uğruyor.
Çok küçük daha, gözleri gülerken falan.
Yani çocukluğu dört yaşında
kalmış bir insan.
Bu sadece Türkiye’de
yaşanan bir şey değil.
Dünyanın her yerinde, insanın olduğu
her yerde yaşanan bir şey.
Maalesef.
Benim bu kitabı yazmaktaki
amaçlarımdan bir tanesi:
Pek çoğunuz ensest ile ilgili
bir muhabbete girerseniz
ya da böyle bir haber gördüğünüzde
şeyi çok duyabilirsiniz:
"Ülkenin doğusuna gidin, çok var;
güneydoğusuna gidin, çok var. "
Öyle bir şey yok.
Birincisi, bunun rakamı
hiçbir zaman bilinemez.
Çünkü bu çok kapalı kapılar
arkasında yaşanan
ve hiç kimsenin anlatmadığı bir şey ki
kendilerine bile söyleyemiyorlar.
çünkü unutmaya çalışıyorlar,
yaşamadıklarını zannederek
yaşamaya çalışıyorlar.
Ülkenin Doğu Karadeniz’i, İç Anadolu’su,
İç Ege’si, Güneydoğu’su, Marmara’sı
almış başını gidiyor.
O kadar çok ki...
Dediğim gibi bunun rakamı yok.
Peki, ben neden böyle bir konuyu seçtim,
tercih ettim ve yazmak istedim?
2015 yılıydı, bundan üç yıl önce,
Türkiye Kadın Dernekleri Federasyonu
başkanı Canan Güllü ile
kadın cinayetleri konuşacağımız
bir canlı yayın yapacaktık.
Ama öncesinde, onu programa almadan önce,
neler konuşacağımızı konuştuk.
Arada ensestle ilgili bir kelime geçti,
ensestle ilgili bir röportaj
yapalım dedim.
Ensest nedir? Bunun cezası nedir?
Eğitimle alakası var mıdır?
Hastalık mıdır?
Ülkenin sizce en çok neresinde yaşanır,
yaptığınız araştırmalara göre
çıkan sonuç nedir?
Uzunca bir röportaj yaptık,
cnnturk.com için.
Normalde çok uzun röportajlar
okumayız değil mi?
Gazetelerde tamam ama
internette bir yerlerde
artık yarısına kadar okuyup çıkarız.
O röportaj, 2015 yılının en çok okunan
11. röportajı, haberi oldu.
Neden bu kadar çok okunmuştu?
Çünkü halihazırda istismara uğrayanlar
vardı, bir çıkış yolu aramak istiyorlardı.
Uzun yıllar önce bunu yaşayanlar:
"Acaba şu anda ben bunun için
bir şey yapabilir miyim?
Ve beni mağdur eden kişi mahkum
olabilir mi? Buna bir ceza gelir mi?"
Bir diğer taraftan, röportajın içinde
fantezi arayanlar vardı.
Sonra mağdurlarla
röportajlar yapmaya başladım.
Ve her mağdur röportajından sonra
bana onlarca e-mail gelmeye başladı.
Ve bu röportaj sosyal medyada paylaşılıp
altına herkes hikâyelerini
yazmaya başlamıştı.
Görünenin arkasındaki
görünmeyendi, o kadar çoktu ki.
Herkes hikâyelerini yazıyordu.
Ve bir gün Zülfü Livaneli ile
otururken “Büşra” dedi.
“Mağdurlarla olan bu yaşanmışlıkları
bir kitap yap bence.”
Doğru, güzel. İnsanlara ulaşmak önemli.
Ama onlara ulaşmanın yolları olmalıydı.
Bizim gazetelerde gördüğümüz
beş altı satırlık bu tarz haberler.
Aslında o altı satırın
aralarında yıllar var.
Arkada kalan çocukluklar var.
Dolayısıyla iskeletini oturtmaya başladım.
Düşünmeye başladım.
“Acaba insanlara nasıl ulaşabilirim?”
Birincisi, herkesin anlayabileceği
kapasitede yazmalıydım.
Sadece okuma yazması yeterliydi
bu kitabı okuyacak olanların.
Dolayısıyla terimsiz
bir kitap yazmalıydım.
Sosyologlarla röportajlar yaptım,
adli tıpçılarla röportajlar yaptım.
Cezaevlerine girdim, mahkumlarla
görüşmek istedim, görüşmek istemediler.
Çünkü bunu kabul etmiyorlar.
Öğretmenlerden çok vakalar geldi,
avukatlarla konuştum.
Bir film yönetmeni ile
konuştum. “Atlıkarınca”.
Adli tıpçılarla niye konuştum? Çünkü
3-4 yaşındaki çocuk istismara uğruyor.
Ve bu çocuk genital muayeneye
nasıl hazırlanır?
“Doktor bey,
siz bu çocuğa ne söylüyorsunuz da
ondan sonra o sandalyeye oturtuyorsunuz?
O çocuk o sandalyeden kalktıktan sonra
nasıl bir ruh halinde oluyor?”
Sosyologlarla konuştum.
Çünkü olayın göç ile ilgisi var mıydı?
Çok kalabalık bir evde bunun
olasılığı daha mı yüksek?
Eğitimle alakası var mı?
Bunları konuştuk.
Bu arada eğitimle alakalı değil.
Çünkü doğru bilgi ve iyi eğitim dürtüleri
kontrol altına alabilen şeyler değil.
Cezaevine girdim.
Ki ben de bu kitaba çalışırken
çok fazla şey öğrendim röportajlarda da.
Cezaevi psikologları,
Türkiye’nin her bölgesinden
olmasına dikkat ettim bu arada,
her bölgeden bir cezaevi.
Tabii o kişileri, o mahkumları bulmak
zannederim bir yılımı falan aldı.
Barolarla görüştüm bir yıl boyunca.
Tecavüzden yatan bir adamın ziyaretçisi,
hemen değil ama bir süre sonra, eşi
ve eşi onu ziyarete geldiğinde
pembe oda istiyor.
Tecavüzden yatan kocasıyla
Pembe oda, eşiyle cinsel
birliktelik yaşadığı oda.
Ensest mahkumları,
e bunların ziyaretçisi kim?
İlk zamanlar hiç kimse ama bir süre
sonra kendi anne ve babası.
Çok enteresan değil mi?
Kadınlar kabul etmiyorlar eşlerinin
o kıza tecavüz ettiğini.
"Yapmaz ki benim kocam." diyor.
Ama bana sorarsanız biraz sosyolojik
olarak irdelemek gerekiyor.
Bir yerlerde ekonomik özgürsüzlüğe
dayanan bir şey çünkü.
Hukuki olarak da bunun cezası nedir?
Cezalar caydırıcı mı?
Başka ülkelerde bunun cezası ne?
İyi hâl indirimi böyle
davalarda neden yapılır?
Çünkü bahsettiğimiz şey, çalıştığım bu
konu; insanın üstünde, her şeyin üstünde.
Ekonominin, paranın, girişimciliğin,
siyasetin, her şeyin üstünde bir şey bu.
Çocuk. Umut yani, umut çocukta!
Düşünsenize, şöyle karar
veriyorlar mesela;
istismara uğrayan bir çocuk
düşünün, bir vaka.
Bazı hâkimler çocuk istismara
bu karanlıkta uğradığı için,
istismarcı karanlıktan faydalandığı için
cezasını arttıran hâkimler var.
Ama bazı hâkimler de
iyi hâl indirimine gidiyor.
Mesela yaklaşık bir buçuk iki ay önce,
bir kız babasından hamileydi.
Hamileliği bitirildi.
Kız zihinsel engelliydi.
Karnındaki çocuk %99.9 öz babasındandı.
Ama o kız, tecavüz esnasında bağırmadığı
için o istismarcı babaya ceza verilmedi.
Hukuk, adalet bunu uygulayanların
vicdanına kalabilecek bir şey değil.
Bir kitap var, orada
ne yazılırsa o yapılır.
Ya ağırlaştırılır ya da orada olan
uygulanır ama iyi hâl indirimine gidilmez.
Peki bunlar içeride ıslah oluyorlar mı?
Bence hayır.
Pişmanlık yaşıyorlar mı?
Çünkü zaten kabul etmiyorlar.
Sordum, dedim ki psikologlara:
"Sizinle görüşmek isterken
dilekçelerine ne yazıyor bunlar?"
"Ya uyuyamıyorum işte,
bana bir uyku ilacı yazar mısınız?"
Bu sebeple psikologla görüşmek istiyorlar.
Mağdurları bulmak hiç kolay olmadı.
Çoklar. Çoklar, gerçekten.
Ama onları bulmak zor oldu, onlarla
konuşmak da çok zor oldu.
Mesela ben yaşlarda bir kız.
Aynı dönemlerde çocuktuk ama bambaşka
hayatların çocukluklarını yaşadık.
Aynı gökyüzünün altında, ben ip atlar,
ben sek sek oynarken
o kız, atladığı iple kendini
boğmayı düşünüyordu.
Böyle bir çocukluktu.
Ama hiç kimsenin
böyle bir şeye hakkı yok!
Onlara soru sorarken onları
incitmemeye çalıştım.
Bana cevap verirken
çok uzaklara baktılar.
Ama uzaklara bakarken aradıkları şey
altı yaşında kalan çocukluklarıydı.
Amcası, çikolata veriyor.
"Gel sana çikolata vereceğim."
Kız gidiyor.
"Altı yaşıma kadar çikolata yememiştim,
paramız yoktu diyor.''
"E amcam, gittim aldım."
Ve bitti, altı yaşında kaldı.
Bu kadar kolay mı?
Hayır.
Bu bitirilebilir bir şey mi?
Bence hayır.
İnsan soyu devam ettikçe
maalesef olabilir bir şey gibi geliyor.
Ama en azından gardımızı alarak
bilerek yaşamak çok önemli.
Peki ben bu süreçte nasıl etkilendim?
Benim için çok zordu, ben çok değiştim.
28-29 yaşlarındaydım buna başladığımda.
Saçlarımdan beyazlar çıktı,
tamam yaş itibariyle olabilir.
Ama bir anda bu kadar çıkması...
Saçlarımdaki beyazların her biri, aslında
biri; hepsinin birer hikayesi var.
Kendimi dışarıda tutmaya çalışarak,
biraz daha güçlü, dik durarak
mücadele etmeye çalıştım,
onların sesini çıkartmak için.
Başkaları da o noktadan,
o yoldan geçmesin diye.
Mesela artık bence gülüşüm de
yüzüme oturmuyor.
İlk dönemler otobüse bindiğimde,
demirlerden tutamazdım.
Oradaki terler avuç içlerime
gelecek diye...
Otobüse oturduğumda o sıcaklık
bana değecek diye...
Öyle dönemler geçirdim
ve bunu kabuslar takip etti.
Ondan sonra 70-80 yaşındaki dedelerin bana
hiç tonton gelmemesi falan devam etti.
Ama şöyle bir şey var.
Neden?
''Git oğlum amcan biraz seni sevsin.''
''Hadi kızım yanağından...''
Neden?
Niye dokunsun ki başkası benim çocuğuma?
Dokunmasın.
Neden?
Bir anlık! Bir an!
Bir an eşittir 65 yıl.
Düşünsenize!
Kitap çok ilgi gördü.
Çünkü bu konuşulmadığı için okunması
tercih edilen bir konuydu.
Çünkü okumak sessiz bir eylemdi.
Ama o kadar çok dönüş alıyorum ki;
doktorlardan, öğretmenlerden,
sosyal hizmet uzmanı olacak öğrencilerden.
Herkes bambaşka hikayeler anlatıyor.
“Tez gibi bir kitap olmuş, iyi ki olmuş.
Üç yılda okulda görmediğim bilgileri
hap hap buradan aldım.”
Neden?
Ben gazeteciyim,
ben sadece soruları sordum.
Okullarda da bunun eğitimi verilsin.
Kitapta yazıyor: "Hangi uzmanlar
okulda hangi ders olursa
meslek hayatına girdiklerinde
faydasını görebilirler?"
Bence kitabın en önemli ayaklarından
bir tanesi, anket çalışmasıydı.
İki bin küsur üzerinde
yaptığım bir çalışmaydı.
Hedeflediğim kitle üniversite
öğrencileriydi; hukuk, tıp, eğitim,
güzel sanatlar ve iletişim fakültesi.
Neden hukuk?
Çünkü bunun cezasını verecek
kişiler bu fakülteden çıkacaktı
ya da savunacak kişiler.
Neden tıptı?
Çünkü bunun raporunu
verecek kişiler tıptan çıkacaktı.
İletişim, olayın basın ayağıydı.
Eğitim, öğretmenlerin
kocaman bir rolü vardı
ve güzel sanatlar.
Fakat bu çocuklar üniversite öğrencisi
ve ben ensestin tanımını
yapıyorum anketin başında
ve sorulardan bir tanesi:
"Enseste uğramış birini tanıyor musunuz,
kim tarafından uğramış?"
Verdikleri yanıt: "Sevgilisi tarafından."
Okuduğunu anlamıyorsun,
sevgilisi yazıyorsun.
Sen daha sonra çıkıp bunun
raporunu nasıl verebilirsin?
Bunun cezasını nasıl verebilirsin?
Yani bunun cezasını veremez
ve raporu da veremez.
Biraz daha dikkat, ne olur
biraz daha dikkat!
Umuyorum ki çocuklar
sadece gülmekten ağlar.
Umuyorum ki çocuklar yere düştüğü için,
dışarıda dizleri kanadığı için ağlar.
Ama çocuklarımızı maalesef artık dışarıya
gönderemiyoruz; evde kalsalar maalesef.
Ama şöyle bir şey düşünün:
Kocaman bir siyah düşünün.
İçinde minicik bir beyaz
kendini belli eder değil mi?
Yani bu ne demek?
Karanlıktan güçlüdür hep
aydınlık ve umut çocukta.
Beni dinlediğiniz için çok teşekkürler.
(Alkış)